and I feel like I was like I don't think
we've ever I've seen you so much yeah I
feel like we've met but we have never
met we haven't but I feel like we I feel
like we're connected I feel like I'm I'm
gonna choosing to be a part of your
Sisterhood
um thank you that was an easier
right away thank you thank you so wait
you you guys both have kids now we all
have kids very young as well you have a
real young I have a little baby six
month year old six month year old six
months six months is so young are you
sleeping I'm sleeping oh like a good
sleep I feel guilty for anyone in the
audience that has a little baby she
likes to sleep oh that you are so lucky
I'm so lucky I have a puppy right now at
my house are you sleeping no
good idea on paper when was the last
time you slept I sleep but it's just
broken up because she's little so she's
a little bladder so I mean around 3 A.M
situation in that way that's what I'm
saying it's like have a tiny bladder
Club yes like yeah but at least that
one's wearing a diaper I'm like I was
doggy diapers I just let her go give her
a bath every
forget like wait but you don't it's
you're in it and your kids are young too
though right well my youngest is two I
was gonna say that yeah yeah and he's
young I just potty trained him so I feel
you're out of diapers that's a victory I
feel so proud of myself
[Applause]
[Laughter]
train when the diapers were around oh my
God that's a beautiful thing when like
bottles and diapers kind of just drift
away I know but now I'm sort of like do
I have another one but no I mean yeah oh
my God that hits us that's what we do
yeah I know it's evolutionary I don't
yeah yeah you forget how mine was
miserable
um did she give you any like motherhood
advice well I got to see her be a mom
that's how I learned to be a mom but my
little nugget shocked me and she came
almost six weeks early when I wasn't in
New York which is where I live I was in
Maine yeah I woke up at four in the
morning and I went into labor and all of
a sudden I'm Googling hospitals nearby
what and we made it I would have been
terrified yes I mean I was but I didn't
know what was ahead of me so it was sort
of oh my God the unknown I didn't know
yeah anyway we made it share arrived
like an hour after we arrived at the
hospital and she had to be in the NICU
for the first four weeks and we were
totally unprepared we thought she was
going to come on her date so my sister
luckily flew to Maine went to Target oh
where you can get it all oh yeah I got
and by the way I know what to get I'm
like okay yeps to the Aquaphor yes the
diapers the car seat we had no means of
taking her home from the hospital yes so
I don't know that she gave me advice but
she just stepped up and helped me get
that little nugget through her first few
months of Life yeah and her name is Cora
Georgia coin
Georgia after my dad and grandfather so
my dad just calls her see George thank
you George it's like she's learning to
read
yeah so she doesn't know what to answer
to yeah
um but all of their grandkids call them
my dad's nickname is Jefe which means
the boss in Spanish okay that's
self-appointed yeah chosen like a little
grandchild was like I'm going to call
you Jefe he chose it in advance and now
he's taught this yes basically he was in
retirement and nobody was calling him
the boss so of course yeah so he's like
hey you it was a power struggle within a
little bit yeah I love that that's a
cool name so you guys turned 40 a few
months ago so what am I what should I be
prepared for everybody keeps saying I'm
gonna just go blind you are what you are
what and I and somebody said that to me
like today's LASIK surgery we got it but
it doesn't matter at all Savannah and
Hoda said when you turn 40 you're going
to need readers like the day after and I
was like no no no I've got great
eyesight I have like 20 20. the day
after the day after so I'm looking
forward to some cute little readers yeah
yeah and looking at Stu
[Applause]
Dallas Cowboys cowboy boots are these
pom-poms
because we know that you were from
Dallas too and we wanted to make sure
that you were wait I wasn't a
cheerleader I didn't know Paul was doing
both sides by the way neither do you
think yeah they didn't accept this no
they were like you're crazy
um I didn't I thought they only had
Palms on one side they have double yeah
that's true dancing These Boots Are For
You I love for your 40th oh and we got
you an Aerosmith t-shirt because we know
you you know me so well you were
oh Aerosmith combined with Texas we also
got you some tweezers because hairs grow
in places
it's a 40s thing hair is growing places
you guys it's literally this is a real
story and I'll take them I was on
vacation with my girls and all of a
sudden I came in and how the light was
hitting my face I had a full-on blonde
beard yeah at least at least blonde it's
so blonde but it glistens in the sun
like I'm a vampire from Twilight it's
literally the Sun and then my friend
came in I thought for sure Trisha was
going to be like oh no said about she
was like oh my God you do and I was like
and it literally I just have so much
pizza it's like it's like a I have a
blonde beard well I'm listening always
blonde
no then randomly TMI brands of black
yeah
look at these women they're like we know
I and it wasn't there at night time it
came in the morning grew in the night
yeah and it and I had a hair and I was
like what I mean it hurt well that's why
you need a sister to pluck it for you
sometimes you need a gun I will punch
someone I have to plug myself in people
try and do it I'm like it hurts it does
I do it it doesn't hurt I love your gift
anyway happy birthday wait what's this
wait wait wait yes wait I would have
been here we forgot no no yes wait so
it's called the superpower Sisterhood I
love this I read to my kids every night
we've done the camping one you know yeah
so I've done that one so my kids are
gonna love this why did y'all want to do
this what's it about well it's about
Sisterhood it's a love letter to
Sisterhood both blood sisters like us or
besties that are like sisters we um we
wrote a children's book called sisters
first a few years ago and on tour all
these women would come up and say I
don't have a sister but I brought my
best friend with me yeah and we were
like well that's your sister Sisterhood
can be so much bigger and so our story
is about a girl named Emma who's an only
child the way that our mom was yeah and
she starts a Sisterhood with the other
girls on her block and they're super
powerful they're superpowers aren't like
Supernatural That's What I Love yes it's
like one is good at math one is like you
and is excellent at music one's a dancer
one's an architect but like together and
I feel like we all know this with our
best friends yeah like we want friends
that feel that light us up you know and
that find the the beauty in us and make
us feel super power yeah I know that
super power absolutely wait what were
your super like what was your superpower
you feel like growing up Barbara's
superpower I never shut up that's mine
you have a real superpower also yeah
you're in your incredible musician you
forgot about her singing when I was a
kid they were just like stop talking but
you understand that that's the power if
we I love talking if we could I'm a
tiger I don't would give up talking for
singing I know I wouldn't I I don't know
if I could do that yeah I don't know if
I could not talk I would give up talking
for singing But Barbara's superpower was
math she actually when I was little one
no no Barbara don't belittle yourself
in third grade no you didn't she won the
Dallas State math competition in third
grade yeah exactly yeah
[Applause]
and mailed it to me last year so it's on
my fireplace mantle oh my God I love it
I never unfortunately everything sort of
was downhill after third grade but it
was a good moment I hope and pray when
you have people over at your house
you're like and I use this
trophy that's my favorite I love that
um what were you good at what was like
your superpower
chubby little Texas okay and I would try
out for Les Miserables every year
because I wanted to be baby but it
wasn't like her look wasn't the French
Revolution exactly yeah yeah know what I
mean that's only a sister can say that's
me and my sister I was
I was like this doesn't Scream the
French Revolution literally ran is
pointing to break
you've got three Texas women here
okay Jenna and Barbara's new book the
Superbowl our Sisterhood is out now you
gotta check it out you can also see
Jenna co-host the Today's Show every
morning on NBC and follow her book club
read with Jenna I love that you have a
book club um we're playing a game
because I'm making them and I love games
okay good and it involves sisters in the
80s and you're welcome stay here
[Music]